you are one of those trustworthy whites
yeah even when I first met you not you
not so much
but when I met you I was like this guy
this guy would never hang me yeah even
if it yeah because you're like sneak out
there at night and give you water oh
you're like a Schindler yeah while you
were hanging right in where I hang you
what the day before they were gonna hang
you I'd sneak out there that night and
give you water but what if I said hey
hey can you get me out of here I would
say I can't why because they're they're
gonna know they're gonna and I'll die
too
okay but I'm gonna die yeah I know you
are buddy
and that also that comforting it doesn't
feel good let it keep going you haven't
[ __ ] let the scene play out okay look
I know you're gonna let's start from the
top okay okay hold on hold on yeah
so it's night time right right and it's
raining what year is that I have to know
what your it is it's whenever you guys
died dude 70 okay let's just say 1967
and your Alabama more jacked Alabama
Alabama [ __ ] hanging ages Alabama
where's the San Francisco wasn't it
where they killed a lot of Asian people
wasn't that where they are well you know
that was in the for in the 40s during
World War two they had internment camps
yeah but they didn't hang the Japanese
they just put him in camps okay then
this was in China where they did this
China they where was that there was a
ton of remember they would hang him by
their by their hair oh yeah yeah are you
that at I read a couple books about this
when I was in a room okay so look at
pretend I just pretend it's Alabama okay
it's in the 60s cuz you're a white dude
you're southern right okay yeah so I'm
in a cage yeah yeah yeah we're free but
you know I'm gonna kid about to die but
the next day okay well they're gonna let
me roam free like I'm how you're in a
one of those things these things
oh I mean a docker what do you call
those though a guillotine no guillotine
is a knife on it the stalks is the
stalks you my bad my bad yeah I'm gonna
stalk you're in the stalks and so I'm
gonna get me out the first line okay
it's raining okay thanks for the water
even though it's raining oh yeah didn't
know it was gonna be raining yeah but
thanks I was parched no worries
I'll be chopped what'd you call me
nothing go okay I'm just making sure
you're okay
I'm fine yeah but I think they're gonna
I think they're gonna do something
tomorrow like hang me or something
I don't think hang me is like a surprise
party I think oh it is yeah it's not my
birthday or nothing yeah but it's like a
big day for you yeah is it one of my
look I have a feeling it's gonna be one
of my last days uh-oh it depends on how
you look at it like that
that's why I'm actually here right now
to talk to you about Jesus Christ uh
yeah no thanks oh come on guys no thanks
look at but listen um can I just say guy
um yeah
what's your name again my name is Reggie
can I call you master Reggie then I mean
you can master reggie own get us all say
it's you like okay can you sneak me out
of here I'm gonna see what I can do I
can probably come back tomorrow night
and help you tonight I can just give you
water and also have this small bag of
fresh pears oh I love pears thank you I
know you do can you slice them because I
have my hands I can't yeah I'll slice
them okay um but if they're gonna hate
me tomorrow then what's tomorrow night
gonna what is that gonna do yeah that's
a good point actually gonna be a little
late you see something inspirational
don't mean to make me feel colder
yeah comfort me I'm gonna tell you this
that even though a lot of the books and
stuff just showed that God just you know
has like a lot of white people in heaven
that everybody's allowed in heaven and
that you're gonna be up there and that
you're gonna be a king well like will I
be able to go to the white sections of
heaven you can stop by you know yeah
yeah but also there's some ones that
roped off words are offense up there
dude the only thing roped off is gonna
be you tomorrow I'm just joking guys
it's just a surprise oh man okay well
you gonna be you gonna be there at the
party I'll be there oh but don't look me
in the eyes okay can I just say
something about the scene I really
didn't feel comfort in that okay I know
I'm being real I think this is my honest
truth
okay and when I said that you were one
of the good ones I really meant it I
believe that if I was imprisoned that
you would be really caring you would
have tears in your eyes and you would
really care I don't know if you can do
that as an actor I don't have that kind
of depth
mmm-hmm like Johnny Depp yeah but I'm
just letting you know that we joked
around just now but in real life I
really believed that you would make me
cry and go thank you so much sir okay
you can't do it now I don't think I
might be able to I don't really let's
try it real all right so I'm gonna be
real too because okay so here we go
he just taped yeah okay I think they're
gonna kill me what he can't laugh man
you're [ __ ] up it wasn't funny dude
let's do it again sorry I got money
you're gonna pod cut let's do a scene
that right but the way you looked at me
was so sincere it make me laugh so hard
so let's start all right all right I'm
gonna yeah that's supposed to do you
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] I didn't all right
just look away from me and turn to me
like that when I say my line that's what
I get another shot at it
yeah the white dude I don't refuse your
brother or no Rico's I'm gonna hang you
you goop tomorrow you flat face [ __ ] I'm
scared time for you to die you little
[ __ ] snap pea is that it notice let
me try again no that all right that was
looking kind of just say this why'd you
call me that I mean that's just like an
old nickname I think it would wait you
wait in the it's wait from where you're
from you took my agents nappies - look I
don't even know the only person that I
know did except for some like I've seen
on the you know it's crazy as my sister
can't even read but what does it have to
do with us right now hope you enjoyed
that video and you can watch another and
you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices some guy just brings you one
option not this guy
- option
watch one this one against one